قال نائب المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي روبرت هود ان ايران فشلت في
كبح جماح ما وصفها بوكلاه المتطرفين رغم
التحذيرات الامريكيه المتكرره ودع اعضاء
المجلس الى الضغط على قاده ايران لوقف
الهجمات على القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه لقد حذرت الولايات المتحده ايران
مرارا وتكرارا في بعض الحالات بشكل مباشر
من الهجمات على افراد امريكيين ومع ذلك
فشلت ايران في كبح جماح وكلائها المتطرفين
بل على العكس من ذلك تواصل ايران تصعيد
التوترات في جميع انحاء المنطقه لا يمكن
لايران ان تنكر دورها في تمكين هذه
الهجمات ضد القوات الامريكيه او مسؤوليتها
عن هذا التصعيد لذلك ندعو كل عضو في هذا
المجلس خاصه اولئك الذين لديهم قنوات
مباشره مع ايران الى الضغط على
لكبح جماح ميليشياتهم ووقف هذه الهجمات
يجب عليهم ايضا الضغط على النظام السوري
للتوقف عن منح ايران منصه لزعزع استقرار
المنطقه